in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to work with vectors so what is a
vector well a vector is oftentimes you
know drawn as an arrow
or like a ray and basically what it does
it has initial point a starting point
and a terminal point where it terminates
or stops and a vector basically has a
magnitude which is represented by the
length
and then direction which is represented
by the angle so if you were to have
let's say a longer
ray here a longer vector that would
represent like a stronger force for
example
and if it's pointing this way versus
this way that's just indicating the
direction that the force is exerted
so when you calculate the component form
of a vector what you do is you take the
terminal point minus the initial point
so the starting point
i'm sorry the ending point minus the
starting point right so terminal minus
initial so in this example if we're
going from 5 3 to 6 7 you would just
take the ending point 6 minus 5
okay so i'm subtracting the x
coordinates and then seven minus three
so terminal minus initial so that comes
out to one
four
so that means that you're going uh one
to the right and four up okay so this is
the horizontal component that's the
vertical component x and y
so it's different from slope where you
do y2 minus y1 over x2 minus x1 here
you're just subtracting the x
coordinates to give you the horizontal
direction
okay and distance and you're subtracting
the y coordinates to give you the
vertical direction and distance so
basically you just take terminal minus
initial now if you wanted to write this
vector instead of in component form in
what they call unit vector notation
what you do is you write this as 1 i
plus 4j what i represents is a unit
vector meaning a vector that's only one
unit long okay going in the x direction
or horizontal direction and then the j
represents a unit vector meaning one
unit going in the vertical direction so
this is one i mean you're going one to
the right and four up so if we were to
represent this like this you're going
right one up four so there's your vector
right there
okay now you can add vectors subtract
them and multiply them et cetera so
let's just look at some examples if
you're adding these two vectors all you
have to do is add the x components
that's the horizontal components and the
y components so in this case 3 plus 2 is
going to give us 5
and 5 plus 1 is going to give us 6. so
this these two vectors added together
give us 5 6. that's that's the new
vector when you add vectors okay not
just using the component form but just
looking at vectors in general what you
want is where one vector ends
you want the other vector to begin and
you can take a vector and you can slide
it left and right you can slide it up
and down you just don't want to rotate
it and you don't want to stretch it or
compress it you want to keep it the same
size but you can translate it so if i
translate this vector here
in such a way that where one ends the
other one begins sometimes
is referred to as you know head to tail
head to tail like that where one ends
the other one begins the end result or
the resultant vector would be this one
right here so instead of going like this
and like this the end result is going on
this diagonal from the beginning to the
end
that's called the resultant vector now
here when you multiply vectors what you
can do or i should say this is a scalar
multiple you're taking this vector
negative 1 5
and you're multiplying it by 4 you're
making it 4 times
longer and it's still going to go in the
same direction it's just going to be
magnified by four times so here you just
distribute the four to the x and y
components the horizontal components and
the vertical components so that's going
to be negative 420 and that's going to
be
scaled by four times so multiply by a
scalar of four so let's look at a couple
examples see if you can do these on your
own and we'll go through them so
example one says what is the unit vector
notation of vector ef so that's from
here to here so this is
the initial point this is the terminal
point
okay so what you can do is you can
either do the method we were doing here
where we were taking terminal minus
initial or you could go like this you
could make this into a little triangle
and you can see we're going so many
units to the right so many units up okay
but i'm going to use the terminal minus
initial so 3 minus negative 3
and negative 1
minus negative 2. so when you subtract
that's like adding the opposite that's 6
that's going to give you 1. so that's
going to be 6 1 so you're going right 6
up 1. so that's your that's your vector
now in unit vector notation this would
be written as 6 i
plus
1 j or you could just say plus j
that's the unit vector notation
horizontal and vertical
okay now for example two given vector u
and v such that u equals negative one
four and v equals four negative six what
is three u minus two v well here you can
see we're just scaling the vectors okay
three times u is just going to be what
it's going to be negative 3 comma 12
okay minus 2 times v so 2 times v would
be 8
negative 12 and we're subtracting so
negative 3 minus 8 is negative 11 and 12
minus negative 12 is
like adding 12 so that's going to be 24.
so
that's an overview of working with
vectors the component form the
unit vector notation
multiplying adding subtracting and so
forth review this lesson if you need to
and i'll see you in the next lesson